let's bring in our panel there start
with that discussion kimberly strassel a
member of the editorial board
at the wall street journal harold ford
jr former tennessee congressman
ceo of empowerment inclusion capital and
former education secretary
bill bennett bill let me start with you
i mean i've talked to a lot of people
over the past couple of days they're
kind of scratching their heads saying
this is really political jujitsu on the
part of democrats
flipping it around even though a lot of
them are on camera
talking about defunding the police yeah
this is a very hard sell for the
democrats to suggest that they are
strongly behind the police that they're
tough on law and order the only thing
that might help is some tapes from biden
in the 80s when he was chairman
judiciary when i was the drug czar
and he'd say you've got to be tougher on
these people you've got to lock them up
for a longer period of time
but i don't think they want to get those
out what we've got to realize is that
while the most
radical elements in the democratic party
we're talking about defunding the police
or dismantling the police altogether
most of the democrats in the congress
were quiet
the president was ambiguous the vice
president less than ambiguous in the
wrong direction
jim clyburn said whoa whoa whoa this is
a mistake but he did not have a lot of
echoes there
yeah and just to give you a little
montage of some of those sound bites
you don't have to go far but here they
are
yes i support the defund movement
because this is about
the the um investment
in our communities i am for defunding
the police
not only do we need to defund but we
need to dismantle and start anew
many affluent suburb suburbs have
essentially already
begun pursuing a defunding of the police
in that
they fund schools they fund housing
all right and one more sound bite here
this is uh peter ducey asking about
those comments to jen saki he was trying
to say
it's republicans defunding
let's talk about who defunded the police
when we were in congress last year
trying to pass
a rescue plan for cities that were cash
strapped and laying off police and
firefighters it was the republicans
who objected to it how is it that that
is an argument
to be made when the president never
mentioned needing money for police to
stop a crime wave when he was selling
the american rescue fund the american
rescue plan the
state and local funding something that
was supported by the president a lot of
democrats who
supported and voted for the bill could
help ensure
local cops were kept on the beat in
communities across the country
as you know didn't receive a single
republican vote
okay harold where are you on this i mean
straighten this out from a democratic
perspective
so so politics you're going to have
politics i give the democrats a little
credit for trying to play
a brand of politics it may or may not
work by shifting some of the
responsibility here here are the facts
there's there were some serious people
who had some really dumb ideas about
defunding the police
uh a year ago i was not one of them i
made clear that any person speaking that
that book obviously doesn't care about
the people that he or she represents nor
do they live in a community that needs
policing and i might add all communities
do
good policing roots out violence good
policing roots out gun violence and the
awful things that happen and
they're happening in many cities i might
add the great affirmation political
affirmation we have this evening
about democrats if you look at the top
two democrats that finished in the
mayoral race both were against the
funding of police one is a former
captain of the police department and
that was in a democratic primary
democrats are going to have to get away
from this issue though
for all of the obvious reasons i think
secretary bennett is right about the
political predicate and your polling
confirms it bret that
if democrats are seen as being weak on
crime
weak against violence in communities big
cities small cities are like we're going
to lose
i might add republicans need to come
around on this ghost gun issue biden is
right about that but the optics and the
messaging
democrats are going to have to shift and
shift dramatically
to get this right obviously this all
sets up kimberly to the 2022
next round of elections the midterms
we're a long way from that but still
it's a big factor
well yeah and it's why you see
republicans expressing some optimism
about their chance because look
politics is local we talk about this a
lot you showed that poll
and people are seeing crime in their
cities and that is something that really
really resonates with them
and one of the remarkable things here is
why it's taken so long
for the white house to come around on
this because harold's right starting
last summer it was only a few voices
but it's the silence that has really
hurt the rest of the democratic party
and even in the wake of last year's
midterm there were a number of
democrats who lost their seats who came
back to the party and said
we did because of the defund the police
argument we've got to stop it and yet
it's continued on so we'll see what kind
of damage control
uh where this damage control gets them
but once that meme has
sunk into a lot of voters minds it can
be very difficult to reverse that
trajectory yeah former president obama
was one of them
uh last word on on kind of how the 2022
uh races while again we're far away bill
uh are shaping up and the confidence
that maybe you're hearing on capitol
hill
yeah well i think the republicans are
right to be confident but be very
careful
we know how good the democrats are on
these things and
republicans need to be sharp on the
crime issue
again they have to remind people really
remind people of what people already
know you're not going to persuade people
that the democrats are tough on crime i
used to defend donald trump on a lot of
things but if someone said
he's abrasive don't you think i wouldn't
say well
no he isn't yeah he was just swallow it
live with it
and say we made a mistake there and now
we're back on track
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else